Rashaad Brooks was sitting in his car
when the officers arrived
so they'd been called because he was
asleep at the wheel
but the nearby drive-through in a
conversation which lasted half an hour
and filmed on the officers body cameras
they asked him why he was there was he
been doing if he'd been drinking they
conducted a field sobriety test on him
which he complied with mr. Brooks then
agreed to a breathalyzer test which he
failed at that point the officer stepped
in to handcuff him as they wrestled the
body camera falls off but from the car
camera you can see mr. Brooks gravity's
a stun gun from the officer the other
then shoots him with his taser mr.
Brooks runs off a security camera picks
him up shooting back at the officers
with the non-lethal taser he's then shot
twice with a lethal weapon Rashad Brooks
was pronounced dead in hospital he was
27 years old the predictable angry
fallout came quickly the drive-through
was burning through the night with the
fire out the day was one of angry
reflection all here asking why this
keeps happening and with their own
anecdotes of their encounters with the
police when he walked up to my window he
was like this
among the crowd trying to calm things
joy shepherd a local resident for 40
years and a city council worker across
the city
Atlanta's mayor made clear her view
while there may be debate as to whether
this was an appropriate use of deadly
force I firmly believe that there is a
clear distinction between what you can
do and what you should do mr. Brooks his
family say he'd been celebrating his
daughter's eighth birthday shortly
before he was killed
nobody's trying to find a vaccine for
why officers pulled the trigger so quick
on African Americans and so there is now
another name and another face to follow
that of George Floyd the anger here is
raw and the sense of injustice is only
deepening the disconnect between the
police and the communities they are
entrusted to protect is worse by the day
mark stone Sky News in Atlanta